hi I'm Timmy the trashcan and I love
trash popcorn candy wrappers hmm they
all taste so good instead of throwing
your trash on the floor won't you please
give it to me
well thank you for considering your
fellow patrons apples
Oh sugar shut up that's the [ __ ]
re-recording it's the fall yeah it's the
fall right
it's the fall look Mike ketosis doesn't
like know it you know that it's a
wonderful I'm gonna leaf peeping and I'm
[ __ ] gonna leaf peeping yeah
like it's when the leaves change you
make it sound silky and dirty
that's what there's nothing a rapist
would do whoa let's go leaf tape oh I
wouldn't let you near my children if
you're like it's a nice fall day we're
gonna take them leaf leaf peeping sounds
like everything you do is like peeping
tom we're gonna leave peeping and then
we're gonna go skull [ __ ] from pumpkins
you me [ __ ] the pumpkin no I feel like
my dick was too small I never [ __ ] in
trying to think what I [ __ ] I haven't
[ __ ] anything either and I'm kind of
disappointed by that
yeah I mean like the filagot is phil
paper towel with some hand lotion look
at this look at this look at this these
kids are [ __ ] oh yeah she's just
like press-ups against the wall yeah she
says Denny's they eat free here kitty
free what on Sunday okay and Sunday
Tuesday 4:00 p.m. to 10:00 p.m.
oh so so weird Ray's [ __ ] of a town
snort that's not my town this is the
town adjacent we're in long I waited my
only fitness over there I have been here
a while
Ray's accused me of thinking that his
town was [ __ ] and I I do
but now ray is gonna prove that I'm
wrong this is a shopping center I went
to a lot as a kid and what did you do
there
I went to the GameStop and the
supermarket and I didn't really hang out
over the Wendy's there that was nice
it went is still here this is this
McDonald's coming up I worked at I
worked at this McDonald's how long did
you work at McDonough
it go at first for a while I was a you
know cashier and I was bad at cleaning
and it was a mess and my boss came up to
me once and told me anyway come over
here I want to show you why everything
you clean looks like ass so he said that
literally isn't it great when someone
did a shitty job pulls rank and yes
there is a good there's a right way to
do but he was right and lucky you you
take I had a rag all bunched up and he
that spread the rag out more surface
area and I used that knowledge when I
worked at the Morgan I had to clean the
brains matter off the platter the
platter thing was taking pictures why
did you leave the McDonald's were you
fired
um I was just kind of tired of where I
mean I didn't really it was fifteen I
didn't really need the job you know
gotten into kung fu movies and anime at
the time I wanted one of the devote more
time to that how did you quit oh my
store manager and he said to me where
else do you gonna go right like
McDonald's and you were fifteen but he
still knew there was no hope he's like
where else are you gonna go look at me
you see that fryer that's your destiny I
was no I wanted to work the kitchen they
wouldn't let me I wouldn't let you work
the kitchen at McDonald times I was able
to do it but like they were kind of you
know it was too much work lots they
thought you would [ __ ] up the food
delivery system at McDonald's one time
its guy choked me oh well we were doing
is kind of weird you get bored when
things are slow and we're doing an
engine like we walk by he'd be like me a
ninja swiping I do that it seems weird
but the point is so I got a karate chop
yeah so my dad whenever I need karate
chop you cuz it was slow and nobody was
eating cheeseburger something like that
so what one day he was older than me and
taller and bigger and one day
I got behind them because really I was
keeping the joke going with a thing
going I got with a rag I like it like I
ain't really choking I was like I'm a
guy I wasn't really but he apparently he
just gotten jumped tonight before
because I have he was rolling and so he
was all on edge so he just like flipped
me over and started choking me up
punching me and it's pretty traumatic I
went to this great little ah what is
that why you ended up leaving the job
because you know I was uh I was just how
long after the beating did you stay in
the job and was it awkward for months so
he apologized after he thought it was a
guy jumping him is his head Mangano's
funeral home Mangano Cheryl ed Mangano
was the corrupt Nassau County executive
who was I swear to God taking food
bribes there's an I believe it was the
opium police he's being bribed with deli
platters him and his wife and they were
indicted whatever happened to add in
Linda Mangano did they actually get you
know I mean they were like they were
getting their floors done like by she
got a no-show job as a food tester like
they were taking bribes appreciates good
yeah sis fine with us could use a little
more bacon if you ask me I think the
tuna salad lacks mayo it's a little dry
more more please mi how much by being
paid $400,000 yeah sounds fair I said
Boy Scout meetings in that school
academy Music Academy right music shitty
little building that says music on it
and it's clearly just like a music store
for losers who want to buy guitars and
sit around strumming your guitar it's
true this liquor store
you crazy Billy's yeah this was blown up
or they legitly blew someone else's
liquor store price fixing one of those
two things not crazy Billy Ray oh we got
passed by a [ __ ] right here yeah here
we go we're gonna pass debit same as
cash
[Music]
whether you need a rest oh my god dude
this is one of the shittiest bars in the
whole world take a look at this to the
left this is the famous you need a rest
that is a little blood box if you stats
like the Lisa's lounge of [ __ ] Deer
Park I never went there but the hoarder
woman who used to have a hoarder house
on my block would hang out there and she
would you know go home with guys but she
perhaps it was condemned because the
fleur de lis forget that like even the
shittiest bars are places people go to
[ __ ] right you forget that is this place
a car wash here yeah I've been here in
years
you forget that as shitty as a bar is
and its Discoverer yes as the regulars
are people are using it as a place to
get [ __ ] well that even about the case
at least is loud when you went there
kind of but it was kind of a drug bar
but I wasn't trying to [ __ ] anyway the
thing is if you're not trying to [ __ ]
anyone there you don't know who's really
[ __ ] like you've got an idea of it
yeah but you get an idea but will you
watch those videos from the guy the the
the banco gave the guy some of his
videos taken borrowers yeah he's with
women in there and then I guess all
these real old bad ugly looking guys and
just like you know trying to pick up
[ __ ] it's just terrible it's real sad
man banned him on Twitter and then he
just got back into Twitter you just
followed me again the apartment has been
changed to strike lanes strike like
dominos a real charming right rural area
yeah don't say my street name by the way
you know I'm not gonna lose coming to
see you anymore I'm just saying we get
there like you know I'm not gonna say
you street name you think TMZ is gonna
show up tomorrow yeah that's well you be
honest with you that's not the worst
it's actually not the [ __ ] most crazy
concern they're just gonna salt your
mother
[Music]
left-right-left
careful careful
whoo
all sorts of dangerous I know what I'm
doing I don't know I mean you know this
is a nice minivan or the I'm in my
aunt's minivan we're gonna wrestle right
here already it's getting nice and
suburban ray
it's lazy suburban it lacks any
definitive character well exactly we
were a high only holy 20 you know ready
we have a garage sale I mean this is
what he's saying is fine already there's
somebody selling your entire old shoes
so that they can go buy oxycontin in the
parking lot garage sales are a
tried-and-true people's old shoes
they're selling your old shoes did you
know it's a real staple it's a real
Americana state it's real Norman
Rockwell out here if he had painted a
kid trying to get his mother's back
medication she's barricaded in the
bathroom excuse me
great right I forgot so yeah I don't
know there's a community garden let's
take a look at the community garden is
this it to the right it looks like a
loud dead plants well I guess yeah I
don't I do p.m. let's make a left at the
stop sign okay this better be nice right
I gotta be honest it isn't that bad yeah
see you thought it was like a shitty
those kids the kids live there used to
be no actually yeah one thing kids there
and then this house used to believe me
further bullying me I fought back well
is this a kid III kill yourself on his
lawn no that was like that was a
Catholic High School yeah it was my
favorite thing ever
somebody's pulling raising I'll kill
myself on your lawn I'm gonna come in
your house and shoot myself and your
front lawn I think what a great way to
get out it's a great comeback yeah you
know it really it's the suicide bombers
he puts the ball in his court how are
you gonna get me exactly uh this is my
house here we're we're here you know
that's what the people murderer cats
what do you mean they murdered you get
the antifreeze why did they murder your
cat so here it is yeah this is what
happened that trees drooping but uh
that's a ray house it's like ripping
that's a ray house yeah the mailbox kind
of looks like it's got the nice siding
it's a Long Island home
listen this house with this house in the
corner here wasn't there that used to be
a hoarder house where the floors got so
saturated with piss they condemn the
whole house which house is that well
it's one this big one on the corner here
so the so okay but you say used to be
facing like people can realize things
like that were more common like hoarders
we grew up yeah there were houses like
condemned houses on the block people
you'd never see I mean that trope from
the movies was real oh sure you had that
woman you never see there was a woman on
my block named Phi Phi all that she was
like a nasty Conte and would barely come
out of her house and like every like
twice a year her kids would come see her
like that was a real thing that happened
you don't see that as much now she was
really she always had these dogs are
very aggressive they try to bite me um I
mean it just gives you an idea of the
you know people's lives are just
absolute horror no it's a shame you want
good you see me do pilgrim state the the
mental facility is right over so it's
not far from here
I've seen pilgrim stock I mean I
performed in a part of it really or
what's the other one Kings Park one of
them's a iceberg one harshly um states
partially open so pilgrim state I
perform a Keith Keith the one-armed ex
crackhead who was a marine who ran a
sober comedy who ran sober comedy shows
one of them was at the pilgrim state
mental institution they have like a part
of it that is dedicated to rehab and mo
mo was on stage
o the world for mo Diggs yeah and mo is
on stage and one guy now they had to go
to this this this comedy show they were
the hosts as part of their was for the
rehabilitation part of it it's like it's
it's like performance based methadone
Lowe's on stage and he's bombing and a
guy gets up and he goes [ __ ] this and
then somebody goes if you walk out of
these doors you go to jail he goes I
don't give a [ __ ] why he laughed Wow
that's how you know you're doing well in
comedy when people are literally
choosing jail over the rest of your sad
that's that's Rob but
but did Moe didn't stop Moe well it did
he's a comedy now get ahead maybe gay
well I mean that's good for him good for
him well he hit that maybe you like
being gay right that's fine yeah you
know I mean I think I could go further
in life if I were straight to be honest
I mean maybe maybe it's a slight
advantage in the entertainment business
but not really anywhere else
yeah I mean you know the best type I
mean I'm not yeah you could be a little
more fluffy Oh affable I am too gay as
you are to stray right we're not really
a credit to the orientation yes you know
what I mean oh no buddy nobody's really
we're not gonna be on the cover of the
brochure that being said welcome to
heterosexual around that that being said
I've been told by women that I lay pipe
well I were told by a woman online part
they mean actual leg pipe because you're
you know I'm a laborer you're a plumber
I wish yeah I would have been a great
job I mean they make good money and it's
just like it's like Lego it's [ __ ]
it's just like settle it it's putting it
together
it really is like adult Legos yeah you
know it's uh I mean I walking around up
he's putting that is he taking the
garage sale sign down look this is not a
methyl town in potatoes not meth addled
no it's a nice enough tone it's a nice
enough town I agree with you bagel cafe
recent past there's so many fast food
restaurants Long Island loves his carbs
big ofa pizza and pasta where's Joe come
on in for pizza and pasta this used to
be a blockbuster video now it's an
urgent care facility yeah don't have
enough insulin spike with the pizza it's
imposter pizza and pasta there's a lock
in safe building with because it's so
safe you were just talking about nice
and safe it was that's why there's
urgent cares methadone clinics and lock
stores they know it's coming look at
willow pet hotel I never understood what
that is all that washing that head of
that laundry man over there a big water
man yeah that's where I met Jimmy who I
guess he was a he was a next heroin
addict I was like 17 I was my friend
they were like yes doing the load
of laundry and he's telling us about how
he like he hasn't do heroin anymore he
just has about four bags in the morning
just to get straight we're like do
heroin interests them so BA hide his
underbelly I'm not saying as an
underbelly but he was a good guy he was
nice to us he's up for anything
I feel like Jimmy Jimmy went home and
how old is Jimmy he was like 40 probably
his old mother was like you're not
hanging around with that Jimmy you do
your heroin in the house don't be
hanging around with Raymond cop in the
parks one time I was outside my house
and we used to pass by before there's
some guy I was skateboarding outside
trying with Holly
when were you escape boarding sixth
grade dream boy it was chubby bag this
guy is nothing worse than a fat
skateboarding feathers game border
should be real thin and have huge dicks
all right well I'm dumb I mean they
actually have huge dicks or they just
look big because they're skinny I have a
good thing but you know it's also just
Worf attached to you yes as I'm saying
yeah so okay finishing your skateboard
take us there so anyway I was out there
and this guy came over started talking
to me you know days of his youth he's
probably like 19 you tell me how you
still like the old are you like sixth
seventh grade okay I mean I just think
he's think I'm a tease and like you know
these big blowup animals and make like
bombs at home and like they'd like put
cigarette on the fuse too like so I can
get away from theirs I think clang and
put on Emad but boy I shouldn't be
describing this it was so you were just
a morning and he came up to these like
let me tell you about the good old days
it feels like that my mom at one point
came out and started yelling get away
from my boy so he was trying to [ __ ] you
probably maybe yeah he's trying to [ __ ]
her he had a fat he was a pedophile with
a fat fetish I mean look he's like I got
a real fat piece of [ __ ] here look we
talked about how you're like bombs right
movies like movies get it wrong cuz like
movies make it seem like it's always
like this you know his fat greasy guy
who's a pedophile but like we've we been
most people know that the the titans of
industry and the politicians are
actively there
like if you're a pedophile in your slub
you're competing with you know the likes
of you can't do it if your listen things
you ever said is to you do you think
we're not successful because we have sex
with adults and that's probably the
answer right it's probably the solution
so the point is this guy was looking to
burn out so a guy so if he's gonna
forget kid it was gonna be me not you
know some [ __ ] right they were taking
it right go to war with the army you
have Zach yeah interesting that lae move
you ever see that movie
yeah I worked they used some of the guys
work at a camera shop and use the
location so Brian Kubiak susan
succession is great is in this movie li
e and then who is it paul dano right I
believe yes Paul Dano is in the movie
and then Brian Cox is they tryin to [ __ ]
him but then at the end
he's like Brian Cox is like five inches
there's a lot of snow it's a lot of rain
but it's not a lot of dick you have more
than five inches it's like you're a size
Queen pedophile is this that so he
really turns a kid down he doesn't like
to turn him down but he just asked him
to quit and it's like what kind of size
baby better fine Bangkok's you know look
it might be something he ad-libbed
he's just smart guy he's he's right he's
like why this Pat you got in the head of
the pedophile yeah it's like everyone's
really creeped out by old Brian Cox his
dad lives on the movie he's like what
kind of [ __ ] you got they're like ah
this scene is not about that well yeah
and I feel like he's smarter than most
pedophiles would be in this case my
feeling he'd be like well the boy
wouldn't wanna show me his dick so my
challenge his manhood rather and make
him prove he has more than five angels I
don't care
I'll suck one but he gets the job done
but uh the tagline for that movie was
there's lanes going east there lanes
going west and then there were lanes
going straight to hell right and it's
about the Long Island Expressway and it
starts with a kid who goes my mother's
name was Sylvia Blitzer and she died on
the Long Island Expressway it kills a
lot of people Harry Chapin and Lee close
to the whole thing right like and then
he's like then he goes he's friendlies
done by the way I think friendlies is
going to exist
[Applause]
I was at one I didn't go in my was that
one recently show the LA movie is kind
of perfect it's his kid whose dad is a
corrupt builder right he was played by
the guy who like when tell anyone buy
that house some races and there was
randos and they end up playing Sinatra
to like make him like renege in the
contract yeah yeah he was that guy good
guy
so that guy plays the father and then
this kid is like ditching school smokin
like out of it all that [ __ ] and then he
falls in with this group of kids that
are robbing houses and eventually you
get sprayed on by this pedophile it's a
pretty decent representational Long
Island I mean it's not the worst I mean
look you see you seen caption of
Freeman's where was that thing I'm
saying right there's of all I give and
it seemed to me if you guys should make
a movie Li II like this could happen
anywhere like why not make a movie about
like oh we got so many fast food places
around no make everyone fat but you're
leaving out the fact that we have it
there I don't know if there is a place
on earth that has more fast food places
this this strip this yeah is the most
per yeah like square inch or whatever a
really I've been around the country
there is no place that has as many as
great there I mean we don't we don't get
like we just got sounded like a few
years back run six years ago now we
don't put all the little things the
little things but like in areas with his
a sonic there'll be a sonic and nothing
else later there's like twelve Dunkin
Donuts sonic Wendy's McDonald's Taco
Bell oh I can ride a ping all those
rides throat busy
oh well packed yeah Pete because they
love their convenience ramen right now
we're getting on the Southern State
Parkway how many car accidents have you
been in on Long Island five I think one
by my first one was in the city in Milan
City but then I got into one in a one
Long Island when I collided with the
state trooper or last a trooper federal
agents I believe but they let me go yeah
this was
was a great store just dropped you off
actually they dropped you off I wasn't
you know no you fell asleep at the wheel
yeah I was off for a split second I was
so close to home but ey just driving
back from the city dropped him off where
he lived and then uh I was literally two
minutes from home and they nodded offer
a half a second and and then tell us
where you woke up
well collide college in the collision
with the federal officers who unmarked
car who seemed to be in such a rush to
get to the airport they were like we
just have to go and they left the scene
because they just they just transported
Jeffrey Epstein Bryan out back to the
country yeah they're doing some secret
thing and then you just [ __ ] crash
this fat [ __ ] you know what I mean
they're transporting some [ __ ]
high-value detainee they just kidnapped
some scientist from Brookhaven National
Laboratories the pits know him before I
even get to the [ __ ] bridge yeah and
then they get hit Witter or YouTube
whatever there was like I'm we've always
heard with Seymour Hersh but this guy
was saying he witnessed he'd be it was
done in the style of like meet this
doctor who like helps kids with
amputated feet like it was like
heartwarming videos but it was like meat
like he was they showed the Clint the
pictures of the the Abu Ghraib or the
guy like the guy in the hood and like
this is the guy under the hood I think
[ __ ] show the guy who apparently
isn't that famous picture on the road
and he's talking about how he was pissed
on and electrocuted I'll never forget
the electrocution but my eyes were gonna
burn out and he says he witnessed
soldiers raping kids in front of their
fathers you know we believe that yeah
Seymour Hersh said that there are tapes
of soldiers or whoever yeah raping
children in front of their fathers and
if the CIA is very scared that those
tapes will come out I mean do you think
that's like that's part of the portrait
manual like all right so first you they
give you a viagra in case you don't like
kids and then they [ __ ] like or is it
like so I got rope n fil just did it
I don't believe I do literally don't
believe in rogue pedophiles in the last
few years I believe you're a pedophile
you're in a group it might be a poor
group it might be a Knights of Columbus
yeah but you were in a group there is no
with the dark web I don't believe in the
lone pedophile nor do I believe in the
lone shooter who killed Bobby Kennedy or
Martin Luther King or JFK or I'm
starting not to believe in that I'm it's
hard for me to believe in Stephen
paddock you know I'm not saying that
that didn't whether the the Las Vegas
shooting is a guy that has no history or
social media or friends or relatives or
or his girlfriend was he happen to be in
the Philippines and the one guy who
interacted with him directly did an
interview with Ellen and then
disappeared forever and nobody else
interacted with Stephen paddock and his
brother was busted for child porn a
weekend he was arrested rebel and then
disappear it's just do you live I forgot
he's Oh see him paddock no he was killed
right he killed himself
right yeah they're shooting all those
people to make a point I guess about gun
control that was kind of the narrative
for a minute they wanted us to believe
that he was doing it to prove
appointment think people were saying
that people like he was anti-gun and he
just wanted to wake the country remember
that literally was a narrative there
like that's particularly that's
potentially but again this is from the
same media with Chris Matthews who goes
you know politicians are poor so a guy
like they can't travel everywhere like
Jeffrey Epstein just lends him is
planing these politicians and of
spending time with these nefarious
characters because they have money and
then play I'm like oh so the Clintons
are poor that's your argument
I mean look even taking a step from it
I'll give there are guys who I'm sure
favors are done but it's like like who
is this Epstein guy why is he let me let
you know you know when they want some
from you Ronnie you know on some level
they so you probably go well who is he
what like is he in the house [ __ ]
Russian no mom I guarantee you that
there's not one person on Epstein's jet
that was not a multi-million
they're right no collapses this is all
logic it's not young congressman on that
chat right yeah these are [ __ ] let's can
we stop well as the governor of
Pennsylvania uh with wasn't he on is he
a millionaire
they're all milk there's no way there
why am i why am I so broke because
you're [ __ ] you don't [ __ ] kids yeah I
mean was you gets you get ancient wisdom
when you [ __ ] kids what is it no listen
every [ __ ] governor no not one of
them is broke and I guarantee you the
majority of them ray are wealthy they
have over in Holdings over a million
dollars with their house and everything
and listen we're just talking about oh
they can't afford cuz to buy that
argument it's that
oh you can't really afford the fly right
you can't get on a plane I find a way to
do it but the governor of bill
Richardson can the bill originally he
couldn't get on a plane right cuz
everyone would [ __ ] bother him no
we're so [ __ ] it's over I don't know
I mean this is route this is the
southern state becomes the Belt Parkway
by the way I've heard that you listeners
out there and was dangerous top ten
dangerous roads in the world and like
the other roads are like action to the
side of a mountain the belts like one of
the only roads is in like a civilized
country yeah that is dangerous but it's
because people are animals driving
through Brooklyn people don't oppose has
designed it in a curvy weird way with
low overpasses explain why Robert Moses
designed all the parkways it was said
that he loved cars and not people Robert
Moses is the guy that designed all the
park ways to go to Long Island and none
of them could have buses on them he
dislikes certain people more than others
he basically he may not like blacks
right he why he made the overpasses low
so that like poorer people regardless of
their you know race or creed but you
know but yeah there he was originally a
racist but say that the buses couldn't
bust people out are you trying to defend
Robert Moses from the charge of racism
that's so no I'm just saying I don't
think like I'm just
say I don't want to paint the brush that
only blacks and Latinos are poor I'm
sure there's a poor white kids who also
couldn't be bused at Robert Moses liked
them better
he did he demonstrated higher if there
was a way to just get poor white people
in here Robert Moses to the Grinch
moment they're like oh I know but he's
alive he dislikes Cruz at the end go buy
a turkey and take it to the poorest
white family you know and have a feast
okay yeah all right I don't know if
podcasting in a car is illegal talking
on the phone is right is podcasting
while driving illegal I mean pockets are
good wheezing should be illegal I agree
could we be the first people to get
arrested for podcasting while drivers
should be illegal in your bedroom
yes but the point I don't think you saw
the mic you know maybe thought they were
guns can you imagine like pick your
parents you should be like are you
jerking off if they never said that but
they thought it now they're knocking on
the door the like are you pod you've got
no listeners your father's yelling you
you don't have a charge you never charge
you piece of [ __ ] why don't you ask
people to share and subscribe yeah you
gotta tell you you gotta hold their hand
you gotta [ __ ] shove it all you're
sick you're chapo trap I saw cuz I don't
have a goddamn job you just hate the
rich you're not funny so now we're
passing the Seaford Oyster Bay by the
way right this is this is our favorite
thing ever
yeah right before I came in New York
both my aunt Donna and my father said
hey please come stay with us if you need
to and we had hotels for every other
night but Saturday the hotels were like
a grand a night in New York I don't know
why cuz it's Columbus Day and a lot of
people are so I called my dad my dad has
two houses now he's moving from one to
another and I'm like hey ma'am
the first we call aunt Donna were like
hey we mean Ben would love to stay for
night she's like oh yeah this weekend
good she's like we get doing a garage
sale soon so this weekend's not good but
any other weekend you're just gonna show
up you can't lay yeah you can't give him
the heads-up that's probably what it is
at any time yeah my dad goes hey I was
like hey could we stay a night he goes
ah and then he gets on the phone his
wife he calls her over because that
Christina's a 1 he's like yeah it's just
not good this week my parents are saying
with my parents last year at the time
they were Thanksgiving but the cat's had
fleas apparently and left us to go to
their place and they could like start
wasn't loud like okay fine and so I mean
we know this is a lot we resolve this
and then again the cats back Christmas
the cat's got fleas again no this isn't
red they don't want you in their home
this is not I want to pick up my old
guitar from them yeah mom's like what
I'll meet you the train station yeah I
don't know what's going on think if you
come into the house you legally won't
leave like we're not fooling these
stupid [ __ ] things he's gonna get in
here you walk in you just having your
mail sent down you walk in you walk it
waving a light but yet you just light a
cigarette dancing around I love the idea
I'm moving home so I don't know what
you're doing there it reminds me of
things my grandparents and my mom Becky
when I when I was younger when they pull
the same you know like with us go there
a place for Thanksgiving
ah they're semi mom knew like they're
sick like when they're sick really yeah
did we get sick every holiday yeah
[ __ ] dude there's nothing better than on
the holidays the family just saying no
last year my aunt Kathleen canceled
Thanksgiving the night before really
yeah it was just like a pretense
Maddie's not feeling up to it
Oh once somebody gets over certain age
yeah you can use them and then just go
they're not feeling up to it and you
never even have to with people like put
her on the phone Kathleen's like I gotta
go wine deeper be careful relax in the
wheel put her on the phone
Kathleen I mean the reality is she was
she's so loud you do that Peter all the
crosses and the flowers are people
who've died on the southern state yeah I
mean look girls you yell out of it I
used to see you know teenage people or
adults who died in a southern state
they're coming the morgue right yeah
ain't no thing
no saying I saw a girl once she was
trying to cross a southern state on foot
like you know I don't why I do that
party and she got yeah little twisted
whatever and she got a [ __ ] face full
of a truck and died now what does the
body look like when it's been hit by a
truck it was really a truck but I was
just saying you know Civic but uh I'm
telling ya
basically the head feels like a bag of
broken glass it looks relatively intact
often but like it's chronic it's you
know when you like you know when you but
drop a glass sometimes it's kind of like
broken but like still together sort of
it's like that broken light bulb so the
skins hold it together but it's just all
loose in kind of like position x-ray
it's uh there's a lot gravel embedded in
the skin now there's burn marks from
like where either they skidded or you
know we really we hit the pavement often
they'll be a compound fracture on your
arm whatever what did it Brett what
would your breasts look like the same
variety as living women's breasts okay
you're gonna get me on this one did you
look at her breasts leave a cop okay
women have breasts a Turay if a
good-looking guy
OD done heroin and I was at a morgue I
would be curious as to what the guy
looked like you know look at the devil
yeah I'll be honest with you all right
you see everything you see I used to
wonder like look of course you're not
gonna be your doing anything awful
beating off you gonna track this and
you're something about a lifeless body
that really has no appeal to me well I
don't know maybe you just haven't found
the right one perhaps I mean you know
you just didn't find the right lifeless
body maybe we didn't get a lot of cancer
patients cuz they're already seeing a
doctor so we know why they died right
when we coming to a more you get
surprises yeah you get people to try to
make it across the southern stay he
hasn't been to the doctor in 10 years
and that we dies in the toilet figure it
out right yeah it's a fun game of Clue
yeah wife you'll die in the toilet
because they just they feel bad maybe
just [ __ ] this out and they can't yeah
what is weird and tests on things
whatever whoever is going on your sums
wrong me like maybe I just gotta take a
[ __ ]
that's what I look for you maybe I just
gonna take a nice shake and [ __ ] I can
[ __ ] it out just go to see the doctor
Vinny shut up [ __ ] you know it's funny
growing up whenever you felt bad
somebody would ask you did you move your
bowels did you go to the bathroom I mean
look this done it's not a bad kid
especially cuz you know when you're
uncooked me a while to realize what [ __ ]
felt like before like you know sometimes
you havin a [ __ ] brewing but you think
you know something's wrong
we're like you know when you eat the
baseball pasta and you get a little acid
reflux but you think the world's ending
cuz he got hot burp so you gotta tell us
how you kiss out all my blood taken off
from my doctor dr. Ramos he has a
picture of George W Bush on the wall
I'll be the big foxnews fan loves Fox
News loves Bush I said it's Quito good
he goes nah Mediterranean diet fish
vegetables I'm like okay what's the same
it starts out slow Quito fishes
everyone's got their gimmick well it
hasn't much got a gimmick it's like yeah
like you'll have to eat like a glass of
bacon grease if you're doing I tell you
what I had yesterday and you tell me
where I went wrong
sure I woke up with Ben no we went to
Park Avenue autumn for brunch nice we
had cinnamon rolls with honey roasted
almonds yeah
what is salmon rolls yeah the cinnamon
like sticky buns like the cinnamon
sticks no like a roll like a sticky bun
oh look at the actual cinnamon roll
cinnamon roll well I'll tell you right
now that's that's so good but first of
all yeah you don't you're not taking to
account the rest of the day go ahead
I don't walk six miles can you remember
can you so ready first of all I'm fine
I walk six miles okay it's a cinnamon
roll I mean few dozen at a pace you
walking yes yes you got sloth but now
she walked walking six miles you
probably burned maximum 600 calories
seven it's not all about calories
Raymond yeah there's a Madras off my
head 1,200 you need to shake the other
day this count a lot of it is cows you
need to shut your mouth is burning count
well you haven't burned the Calliope on
timeline happy Onkyo this guy that works
in the deli listen we had breakfast
risotto which is night pomp risotto
we had pumpkin risotto sausage then we
had what do we have butternut squash
soup then we add that might be okay but
probably sweet avocado toast with crab
then we had a chicken sandwich with
jalapeno coleslaw
then we had smoked salmon eggs benedict
then we had a s'mores sundae
then we had a creme brulee and then
we're done now we're done I have a bag
of roast beef in my backpack that's what
I mean we did after that we did not eat
until we went and had General Tso's
chicken beef lo mein scallion pancake
and some dumplings you could eat so you
could have eaten ribs with no sauce you
could have eaten beef and broccoli with
no sauce I know I went off my program I
mean look not everyone can have the
the rigorous standards of dietary
resolves I have ceased and I'm not even
kidding
yeah why don't you start a personal
training company I'll ask you listen
listen how big are you now I'm a big guy
I'm three something I don't know I'm
gonna hide three is probably the moment
under that really are you in the high
threes do you think it's bad you think
in the mid threes made the high yeah I
don't think I'm four
you can't go over four fours but that's
what I ran it in I'm only knocking on it
when I when I get before I said no more
look it's tough I know I've been doing
it for a week now about I'm a supporter
of y'all doing your weight loss thank
you I mean I'm gonna do it I'm in shape
I mean more funny people say that means
nothing they go I'm so proud of you no I
mean I do it despite you because you all
you do is call me a fat pig call you a
fat pig you call me something I call
myself a fat pig you've called me if a
big money that you're Hollywood you
can't be fat shaming people no I call
everyone that's fat fat little sad I
call everyone say I'm sad right I don't
mince words and lie like other people
you're big-boned your husky prestigious
yeah you take up space your prominence I
don't resemblance we regard there's a
new clothing company Stavros made me
laugh he sent me a thing where they go
for prides clothing for prominent men
know they're fat there's an emphasis
ramen
McBeal I remember where this fat guy was
suing this woman for not dating him or
something he was gross gross pink and at
the end he she was trying to tell him my
god no you're fine you're doing good guy
and he's like what any of your friends
date me
and she's like well no I think because
of my heft she's like yeah doctor is it
my heft is that the issue well it's not
that ie like okay I appreciate your a
day you get some nice pepper jack cheese
there's a last time you can eat now you
walk around eating meats and cheeses and
you get them out of a bag and that
disturbs many people once you ate garlic
in a frozen yogurt place and you did
that for what a cold well that's good in
the restaurant that's true and you
decided to eat a raw clove of God is
good for your stomach it helps some is
antimicrobial properties say you were
eating raw garlic in a yogurt about
tasting yogurt with their children I'm
tasting garlic it was like a little girl
like she has her mother she's like is he
eating garlic as a microt people I don't
tell you doing porn in a [ __ ] yogurt
place I mean the clove of garlic yeah a
wrong clove of garlic do you buy in the
grocery store kid yeah yeah learn yellow
dog food in the grocery store until you
shouldn't eat that you shouldn't eat
kibbles as a clove of garlic the fact
our country has come you talk about our
country oh man yeah all right how's this
country doing I believe the impeachment
process is like us taking a [ __ ] the
crime yeah I don't know how you mean for
names like economically oh man you're
Batman yeah you're talking about I talk
about it's like a company right well
we've moved past the cash cow phase of a
right we were act we're now in the state
of the client right you started the
business matrix I learned in summer
Community College okay and it was a
there was a startup
growing venture a cash cow when like you
have a very profitable business or
country that you can kind of just you
know siphon them on the other hand
you're sure dark you know activity it's
2005 mortgages you've got like your
house is an ATM right don't when you got
equity you got cash yeah we want to pull
whenever we want to deck
everyone who complains they're all
refinancing their goddamn homes to get
like extensions on their shitty houses
yeah like I'm not saying they're as bad
as the people at Goldman who were
supplying but like almost yuck
unlike relative to what you should be
doing like those guys listen it's a
country of criminals hangover yeah
everybody's trying to get over some
people are better at it than others and
then there's like a few people that are
you know genuinely getting [ __ ] and I
feel bad about you let's be honest
there's a lot of people out there trying
to figure something out
right so on this island on Long Island
everybody's his criminality is rampant
political II it's almost like this
country's so bad as getting so much
worse and there's nothing to do it's a
power thing so I'm like the politics are
bad like I jump is a maniac he's
flouting the rule of law in a way where
I get is he worse than bush what Bush
killed a million people or whatever but
you know started fake wars but you know
he didn't openly flatly Davida torture
stuff and point is it's bad though to be
so flagrantly flouting the rules law
that being said the real problems are
just demographic like all the automation
which yeah drew yang talks about but
like you know what we're being like
[ __ ] price to have a job there really
is we've expanded in a way but this
country was kind of built on a certain
level of it of like industrial output
and my yearbook book is Detroit for
instance like Detroit is there because
the automotive you know business needed
certain people work in factories they
you know they're not doing here anymore
like Detroit shouldn't really be there's
no reason for Detroit to be there now
and that's gonna be a lot of the country
right we've gotten into nooks and
crannies in this country that like don't
really have a really like
job's gonna come here they're not know
why they listen I think those places got
to hold on till when Miami in New York
or underwater well that's a fair point
that's their only hope right I mean they
should be destroyed it's like hey
climate change the best thing that
happened or those some of those rights
are are they red stays because that
would make sense that actually make a
lot of sense if it turned out that they
really they believe global warming yes
wanted to happen like we want it now I
mean that is like you know they'll
become the new shorelines I guess when
you travel around the country which I
had the ability to do when I was on Bert
Kreischer and I do all the time on my
own but we were in Oklahoma and we were
in you know San Antonio Texas in Houston
Texas there's a surprising amount of
resiliency in certain pockets you know
right of the country you know we're in
one of them right now I mean we're in a
very wealthy we're heading into one of
wealthiest areas in the control sure
because we're like we're next to a
metropolis yeah it would be metropolis
for now yeah so the reality is but the
issue is when you leave any of those
cities yeah it does not take you too
long before you're in what Chris Hedges
would call like a sacrifice zone sure it
doesn't take you too long some of the
inner ring suburbs are okay some of them
are still not okay but once you get to
those outer ring suburbs I don't know if
Chris Hedges as a homeowner because he's
nothing about how low the property taxes
you have to see you have to see the
rainbow and the pot of gold after the
storm in some of these spots I know it
might seem dire but but yeah it's hard
to get a job but you're and that's gotta
be so low yo yo yogi
the problem is what people don't
understand about low knots nobody wants
and this is like this is when I was
doing real estate not like the idea of
getting a deal is like people don't
understand what a deal is you know right
uh you anything where you're getting it
did like
true actual deals are few and far
between yeah it's usually because a guy
yeah it's got new job motivated buyer
seller blew his head off in the kitchen
there's still blood on the wall okay
like that's why like you you actually
like how much of a factor is motivated
sellers like people get on your job
maybe or what everybody's an actor it's
an undeniable factor but when you look
at areas like Detroit and stuff it you
know I think the Troy's coming up now
it's getting better but people talk
about some of these areas too like it's
so inexpensive is he's amazing yeah
there's a reason it's in expect there's
a reason it's expensive to live in New
York or the Surat tri-state area yeah
there's a reason it's expensive to live
in Los Angeles County there's a reason
you know people start talking about it
in expensive everything is yeah because
there are no services right there on you
know god forbid you have kids that need
to go to a school like the the roads
suck people can barely find you I mean
listen obviously there are places that
are much less expensive than where we
are and you know this is like a bad
example right now we're on here what is
happening here there's some kind of it's
probably for me dude it's a racing thing
there's a bunch of kids who they want to
take photos of me right they know who we
are right here to the left is the
Americana in Manhasset all the high-end
stores those are the Miracle Mile
without them so this is the Miracle Mile
yeah
the nautical mile is down south the
Americana has your Gucci or Prada
miracle it feels more like just been has
never seen the North Shore of Long
Island the great gatsby I you know the
the the the houses it inspired we're
going to the with a rockefeller man
we're gonna go in there we're gonna see
the wedding there really yeah they it's
not it's not at the Vanderbilt mansion
which are also on Long Island and a
little more up captain Vanderbilt
mansions where we're gonna business I'm
in Suffolk there's some over here are
you talking about the big stone castle
yes you shot a wedding at yeah yeah I
believe it's a Rockefeller mansion
it might have been yeah there's a name I
forgot Felicia I think it's in Sands
Point but it's usually like that like
that's not usually used for that kind of
stuff they're shot Grogg gratifications
number the the Ethan Hawke version
uh he they shot part of it there yeah
and they used it for the show with the
Will Arnett running wild show doesn't
matter
point is I was allowed in these places
that you would think that you know you
were taking photo yeah but I was elbow
to elbow with some real powerful people
of course and uh and I'm sure they were
thrilled they didn't mind it was fine
they found me you know that look they
respect horn well they like seeing a guy
sweat and run around oh yeah they like
seeing a guy kind of get abused you know
they'd like to see a white guy get
abused they like white slaves yeah they
don't want they they like to see how a
fat white guy running around was that
game of success yeah on the floor they
love they love seeing a white fat guy
sing for his supper yeah but uh but then
I put my pictures on the plasma screens
and they were all very like ah this guy
here st. Francis Hospital this is where
my grandmother died of a heart sing with
a pierced her esophagus while doing the
scope or something he was a young kid I
was aware that this was supposed to be
in heart hospital right I know and they
just killed her yeah they killed the her
doctor drives a Bentley doctor is rowdy
Oh God he drove a Bentley he's like yeah
we feel real bad about killing her yeah
we just poke around then they're fine
yeah our bad sorry Hey all right I gotta
go to lunch you might as well take lunch
early let's take lunch early I mean it
was really crazy I remember going out
there did she die on the spot were like
no it took a while we went in to say
goodbye and kiss and huh you know and
she was like not conscious towards again
it's very sad when you have somebody
like that and then you're in the wing
where everyone's dying and you're
looking at all the other families and
they got someone dying yeah
you know and everybody's kind of you
know some people are out smoking BOTS
and some Pete you know everybody's on
their phone everybody's stressed out you
know back at that point I had nothing
going on a comedy pretty much I mean I
had a little teeny bit going on I
remember
I was like you know I was like leaving
that and they're going to perform it in
some bar probably you know or maybe I've
already done like uh I think she's not
in 2018 I'm exaggerating I had more
going on than I give myself credit for
but not a lot not a doctor for your
career in 2018 I could not say enough
good things about rich wallet I started
using one last week and it's changed my
life I had an old wallet for many many
years that [ __ ] and was embarrassing
every time I took it out old business
cards fell out I mean napkins tissues
you know oyster rat crackers you put in
a bowl of clam chowder I would keep in
my wallet I would keep in pieces of skin
I'd ripped off my hands and I would keep
in you know just just dried blood and
all kinds of things you know dudes keep
all kinds of stuff and their wallet that
they shouldn't keep you know fingernail
clippings and you know you know a hair
of a dog to died I mean that's the thing
man people just throw in their wallet I
don't care I would throw with my wallet
if I wanted to keep it I would put my
high-school yearbook in my wallet and
walk around with it like a [ __ ] fool
take out my wallet and all the sudden
there's cocaine and sand falling out of
it dried blood noice Tourette crackers
business cards from companies that don't
even exist where the CEOs were taken out
by the feds it's embarrassing you want a
real-deal wallet
you want something streamlined you want
something sexy sleek go with orig wallet
how many credit cards do you have how
many debit cards do you have everything
is mobile now everything is your phone
get a ridge while I get a phone case
simple boom that's all you need okay you
do not need a [ __ ] crazy wallet with
some [ __ ] you know old musty smell
leaving your pocket
it's ridiculous it's not smart go to
reach comm / Tim and use the code Tim T
IM in the description okay you get 10%
off your order ridge comm / Tim use code
T IM for 10% off your order
that's the reality that's what you need
you do not need your pocket should have
a ridge wallet in it in the front pocket
of your jeans and you should never not
wear jeans
nobody's ever not wearing jeans and
that's just the reality of where we live
now you wear jeans that is it if you're
under 30 you can get away with
sweatpants if you're over 50 you can get
away with a khaki but if you're not at
work you're wearing jeans and you slip
your Ridge wallet in the front pocket
with a credit card or to a debit card
okay
maybe one business card that's your
lawyer in case you go out and you have a
little fun you need to make a phone call
but that's it stop with the [ __ ]
loyalty card from the deli stop with the
punch card from 16 handles frozen yogurt
that your two yogurts away from getting
the free yogurt and that location is
closed down two years ago and they don't
know if they'll honor it in another
location those went out of business 16
handles like a lot of those yogurt
remember you know the whole frozen
yogurt craze is kind of dialing back now
if you were smart you would have
switched from investing in yogurt shops
to pokey
if you were slick Ridge wallet you need
a nice sexy wallets a great conversation
starter
people believe cool what is that what
kind of wallet is Alger Ridge wallet you
know a little high-tech maybe not for
you play it play it close to the vest oh
don't worry about it
- ridge wallet yeah yeah yeah whatever
you know the CIA uses it whatever not a
big deal it's you know
yeah I'm telling you it's a great wait
nobody's gonna get laid
taken out I would you can see my dad's
watch if you saw my father's wallet you
would have known what he failed at
everything not everything but a lot of
things and the wallet was just a [ __ ]
it was like taking out a basket
he had sandwiches in it he kept [ __ ]
a phonebook in it there was just cash
dollars and fives and probably not much
more than that
mounds of nothing a whole bunch of money
that added up to 17 dollars it just made
the wallet look fat and stupid a fat
wallet now means you're poor you see
mean you're rich now it means you're
broke cash means you're like broke now
you should have a little cash a little
maybe one hundred dollar bill to roll up
and do a lot of cocaine off a hookers
ass that is it you do not need wads of
cash well you know what are you a
[ __ ] Tony Soprano reg calm slash Tim
enter t I am in the description get 10%
off the ridge wallet don't be a [ __ ]
loser with a fat wallet with everything
falling out of it you have nothing
you're no one if you carry around that
one have a sleek sexy Ridge wall so now
we're heading into now you have you have
you ever had a wealthy friend this is
something wanted to ask you I've had
have you ever had a rich friend of rich
have you ever had someone that would let
you in their home have you ever had a
friend with a brand-new car what is the
mani
now it's from fiddler on the roof if I
wasn't rich have you had a rich friend
have you ever had a person that would
introduce you to their parents and bring
you in their home I had friends who had
more money than me you know
my hand in a Super Nintendo and Genesis
right that's not exactly what I'm gonna
have friends of wealthy means I had a
few friends in high school that were
wealthier than not but I'm talking about
you know what I want baby I want that
real money yeah why would they be
friends with me what was about you why
do you need to start getting confidence
I booked an adult became friends I
befriended men who I worked with who had
money they didn't listen I kind of
understand that because I had thought
people liked to good personalities no
one does right no one cares if you're
intelligent that's almost always Kylie
they always like say is it kind of like
yeah you're pretty intelligent right so
here's some money
why don't you come at dinner with us no
one cares
it's always kind of like yeah he really
told you you'd think you'd be better off
like you'd think you wouldn't be such a
[ __ ] loser right that's always the
vibe I get when people tell me I'm smart
so I mean I have people is there's
different types of wealth I know people
who are pretty well-off from living nice
areas who kind of worked their way way
up there and I know people you know the
DJ business disappointed and you you had
always told me yeah and I never
understood you would always said I said
maybe if I do like a Netflix and stuff
maybe like rich people will start to
befriend me and you would always said
you you looked at me like I was insane
why would they want I know I didn't know
right so they might think it was
interesting but it's like I had fought
my way through comedy and uh I was but
no one cares like when someone come up
to you after a show is a little too like
familiar and like you know hey tell me
oh you're happy they're there but it's a
little like ah okay like it's getting a
little awkward now
that's like you're doing in the reverse
way looking people get that all the time
like Ben well if Ben didn't have a
fiance Ben could make friends with
really wealthy people cuz people just
like good-looking people around here to
us he's better-looking us a [ __ ]
hotter
[ __ ] with a tree branches better wait
hold on I don't I don't think that's
true I don't think that's true at all
are you saying people would rather see
an otter get raped sodomized I think Ben
is good-looking I think most people I
don't think he's got magnetic good looks
at disarmed and wealthy I'm saying you
put our personalities and and
intelligence in his bot and we do that
no dummy
anyway but I'm let's kill him and like
we kill you and then raise a grudge
right but are we gonna do an award what
are we gonna do with that we're gonna
waste it
my point is that I feel like if I was
good-looking
yeah things would be better am I wrong
what is water wet with you what's your
point I don't think people that's what
I'm saying look why do you think people
think that like rich you have to be to
be interesting and if you're fat like
lizzo had to be the biggest star in
music for people to tolerate her because
she's fat do you critique these people
who like go on their go like yeah ask
Queenie whatever in like the fat like
fat pride no but like that's the level
of insanity like insane propaganda you
have to do just to get people not to
hate fat rock it is true you need to
convince them that they're like the true
beauty I think your aim for beautiful
just to get people not to literally burn
them at the stake
yeah that's show people hated fatter
repulsed by him hated them then no one
hates the fat versus more than the fat
person I know any fat fry have any fat
friends before you not really yeah I
mean I I never I was like the idea of
okay that because I'm fat the only thing
I can do nothing I've done multiple
specials multiple pod kits like there is
nothing worse in the world in this world
is nothing worse than if they're two fat
people team
yeah that's true or a talentless boring
fat purse Oh God if you were fat you
have to have anecdotes you have to go
into every room and start doing a jig
immediately you have to [ __ ] just sit
around that's what been kind of then
does it really have a personality he's
just kind of like he's just got always
tired that's like his personality he's
always like tired like you just woke up
but just tired
looks of a guy who just keeps [ __ ]
on bed my point is that levels to this
[ __ ] I know he's not noticing his yard
the juggling Ben can't pull off like the
dark brooding good looks where you can
be a dick to every right he doesn't have
it like that but he just has this thing
where he's like sleepy and bashful if me
and you were sleeping boards next
wingspan they would tase everyone that
is not like the marker the social market
everyone sig is good-looking ray like
dirty disgusting [ __ ] muscle people
stolen steroids
he's really shy and he seems unsure of
himself I mean I know you're insulted
okay you're good-looking - ray
good-looking - I didn't mean that Ben
was a banish'd 300 pounds less than you
yes and as a full head of hair but I
would my point was right that Ben
doesn't have to have a personality and
he doesn't like me and you have to
[ __ ] dance around we have to [ __ ]
kid around we have to frown the same
minivan right world point is my point is
that okay we're going into Sands Point
now well there's a cop giving someone a
tic it doesn't seem that much nicer than
my neighbor why is there a cop doing
someone it's but we're not there yet you
[ __ ] dummies come here Park
first of all know if you North Street
first of all know a few more trees it
could not be Deer Park let's get that
straight right now that guy's gonna [ __ ]
a nice hat not in a sense
here we go right here the village of
sands point okay you're gonna feel it
change you feel it change and I live in
a horse field yeah that's what rich
people out there Voort says you dumb
[ __ ] all right I don't I'm a better
horse once they can't remember
we're gonna show you all the gases my
stone castle well you slow down is a
winding road you have one hand on the
wheel and you can we not die all right
look at this person jockey look at this
fat mass rock this is what I mean look
at this big oh she's like a third the
size of us I know but she's slipping
she's still a big beefcake so here's
hands point preserve um we're not we're
gonna go in there in a little bit that's
right yeah that's the castle I think
we're gonna man my was bigger I think
actually yeah
I'm just saying Helen Keller knows where
Helen Keller was deaf dumb and blind she
was at Sam's point no it was the Helen
Keller school so there's a lot of media
types that live out here a lot of big
business people this is the Great Gatsby
this is called the e stag Great Neck is
the West tag the e stag is the you know
the older money or whatever so we're
gonna go down here now the houses are
starting to get nice too big you can see
them you can see they're starting there
we didn't do well you have the indoor
tennis court that sounds nice right I
mean it has well you walk in the house
you say you've spent five million a
million house walk in it smells like
sweat nice that's it well I'm sure what
it is these people have friends right
don't get angry at them exam parties in
France yeah okay there's too much like
the hill deep in the hills are alive
with the driver waves it's crazy yeah
but these are these are Hills easier
this is wine to drive up that in the
snow
yeah Wow that is true I guess we should
just live in [ __ ] Deer Park I mean
looking flat flat land flat land it is
flat land flat lands the cops enough to
work hard when they pull you out of your
house cuz you had a domestic me dying by
the way a lot of these people can
imagine you dying in one of these houses
cuz that's what would happen if you went
in one of these houses you would be
killed
okay see that on the hill Ben see these
are rocky yeah you're right right
until attack is a beautiful classy spot
okay it's very nice over here I can't
wait till the cops plus over there like
what the [ __ ] are you doing we're
podcasts and you like cut this [ __ ] out
I mean sans point you know you're
looking at
four or five million dollar homes you're
looking at beautiful property you know
really this is my window up I wanna see
something if something this nice fans
point error no it is nice the air is
nice it's fresh you got fresh you got a
fresh air and you know what it is -
there's no commercial establishments in
Sands Point there's no sidewalks in
Sands Point it's just a maze of tree and
men's I mean this is really it's real
residential living so I'm a dreamer
realtor isn't like we're taking somebody
around in this heavy van like why are
you working with these - anybody listen
their methods seem a it seems like
unconventional but these are the two
best realtors on the North Shore Long
Island the houses are very far away is
what's your name mrs. Chang mrs. Chang
smell that mrs. Chang that's the smell
of grass not the smell of rape children
right but you can do that too mrs. Chang
no that's the point is that you want
you're far away you can spread your legs
out so here we go right now this is back
then what happens there who go who goes
negate well that's the Gatsby
yes why the long a date that's Daisy
Buchanan's house for some why I look
like a [ __ ] like rape cage because
what do you think it is right why do you
think it'd make all this money she could
eat Chateaubriand because people want to
[ __ ] have a little fun you know what
I mean nobody's making this so hear you
that's you think people want they hunt
people here ever I don't know probably
why wouldn't I I like it so bad you see
the water oh you know I want you to see
it let me see it
okay that's it nice yeah this is on the
water you get a great view in New York
City you dumb [ __ ] this is all my
friends lived here I grew up here even
though anyone here
I do right have not actually I probably
have met some of these people here you
can see the homes right on the water
where did you photograph Charla and
here's my yeah you can tell mafia and of
course when he was due the brain you can
always tell them off your house you know
there were lots ever Carla yeah you like
yep mob
mafia nothing wrong with that they're
just trying to make their bones see
these are these are not it's a nice
place to label like rich yeah right yeah
oh yeah how many people who were like
who benefited directly from the Iraq
world now multiple people right I mean
this is you know there are some people
here that are but no this is this is
massive like intergenerational wealth
nothing is like 10 million 20 million I
mean you want to see a crazy house
now it was even a road no look bad see
that what is that place it's a [ __ ]
modern house really yeah Waldo Emerson
make that or something yeah that's what
I Frank Lloyd Wright Center for Disease
Control other what it is if I invented
AIDS here
that's what Ray was born baby was born
on Plum Island
Reza I was born on an island called plum
I slammed her saw I had a rib sham a
Riblet body was melted American cheese
it was keyed out I said no Josh there's
a little residual there's a lily he
discards a little residuals I got a vat
of sauce it's okay if that had some
residual you got to get raya sauce if
you want to Quito right then three grams
of sugar no sugar yeah that seems what
Bernard tomatoes no good no you could
have tomato you could have tomatoes
Ankita
really yep I have always been told no
well hoots telling you Ray dr. Atkins
shut up he doesn't know anything about
Kido Kido is a little stricter it's a
little different I'm telling you what
can you hear that gets you can yong-ki
oh I don't really know but I think
[ __ ] I think more of it you know
more vegetables and stuff on Atkins I
hope the whole idea of Atkins was
ketosis
I mean colicky like all these guys
calling a keto and like you're all
rebranding you look at the
houses please inside [ __ ] and enjoy some
bacon we're gonna eat later just enjoy
this is a nice treat for everyone
they're having a party here oh let's ask
them what they do we're here ask them if
they work in the defense industry don't
do it they'll call the police
just wave wave to them it's a team
something that there is torture torture
they have tie-dye shirts team torture
and they're going into a house and
they're going to sacrifice a child
it's Sunday baby I've never seen this
many cars yeah this is the pro I let you
this is a big event it's a big political
event or something yeah Joe Biden Joe
Biden Sally I wouldn't it be great if
Joe's here dude how great would it be if
Josie they're just saying the N word
listen we all hate I work for that
company beep trying to tell me what to
do uh so we've left Sands Point now
we're ok so what was that cause that was
just the reserve no it's one of the
roads right you know that was just a
road that fell by got weird like a
wildlife preserve for rich people that's
probably what it was I mean like you're
like oh you were rich people like when
America is no longer they'll still
they'll still be living there yeah I can
observe them living in there naturally
they're rich appetizer yeah take take a
tour around there oh you'll get the win
there if you if you salvage enough rats
in the in the great rat competition they
have in New York City in the great rat
competition in New York our rats and
they sound bad as it sounded can with
the windows open Gregg get the more the
kid gets the most rats gifts of witness
poor people I mean rich people I don't
know if you were running for president
right tell me how it happened look
here's what we gonna do we got everyone
wants to tax the rich I want that book
we pick 10% of the rich at random and we
seize their assets okay interesting
you would still be wealthy this that
America is built on damn bling
yeah that's what we are working it's
really you came on the Mayflower it was
a [ __ ] gam it was your risk you know
I mean yeah you bought slaves I was a
little more of a sure thing I guess but
they could have gotten sick they
could've gotten sick so absolutely you
know half of your slaves is a gamble
you're many people in America gambled on
the health of their slave you pay yes
what this country was built on you
financed a whole slave and not knowing
if they were healthy or not yeah finance
a war yeah maybe it's Vietnam and you
guys get [ __ ] evenly so our
helicopters who knows so the point is we
pick 10% you [ __ ] and yeah maybe you
get got we murder you and man see the
arms in the back see that we put a
guillotine on the Washington Monument it
drops down these are some rich kids and
rich families for all to see and then
but 90% of the wealthy get to keep it
and then you lose all right take a look
here that right there's one of the guys
he houses guess he wasn't a real thing
right shut the [ __ ] up okay I've got
four general dumb [ __ ] you over here
actual Gatsby house this is West Egg
this is East Egg you [ __ ] didn't
guess we live in West Egg you gotta make
a left here and then you got a point and
then instead of coming down here you're
gonna make you take we're about to be
shot asking for directions right ease
your distract us and then we're gonna be
late executing the other side maybe a
knife right to my neck this is like that
guy you've heard the story when the guy
was like hey that's the Empire State
Building this is right now this is no
good no good that guy was just getting a
look at us so here's this is the Hearst
Castle oh really
it's used to be they owned all the major
we did the Citizen Kane building either
they own printing press in the presses
they owned all the press this used to be
the old Hearst Castle right here that
was the entrance to it this is what I do
okay
yeah just a my loafers I'm gonna do I
don't know
we're from Citizen Kane okay this is a
private round we probably will go to
jail now yeah but this is uh the head of
Arizona iced tea
Oh Wendy lives around here
Wendy lives here Yeah right in this
house right there came to the house
we'll get this shot there's a dead end
and just like cobblestone streets cars
beeping they're blaming us
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is Class C that's hooter mansion
now Tudor is brick now here is why was
that cross all about that rosy castle
this is this is now this is why you buy
a house like this which is what road
seems I smell terrible they look to the
right look at that view of bad you see
that it looks like New York City looks
like a shadow with anything great I have
a better view from my roof first of all
you ball of diabetes that is the cover
of The Great Gatsby book Ray looks oh
look at this person oh god [ __ ] man you
killed that guy I should [ __ ] we'd be I
should kill him there's always a you in
a sense point bell crow just a big perv
yeah this is the this is the North Shore
the beaches sock there rocky you know
the water is tepid it's not you know
it's fresh water because it's a Long
Island Sound here to the left look at
that pen that's that I think that's all
for like 12 mil
[Music]
you know just that's a thing just twelve
the people who live you have so much
more than twelve million probably right
now but you know I feel like I could get
12 million somehow yeah but put it this
way buddy you can't no you I'll tell you
this you can I've always I've taken your
tour a bunch time yeah you talk about
the Dakota and Haney Springs truck full
of intial records yeah is there a
similar process to move into a like
listen you just gotta buy the [ __ ]
house now dude people were coming in
here to with like jacked up mortgages
and [ __ ] oh really yeah they were
getting you know people were I mean they
were buying they were getting jumbo
loans you know the jumbo market was
loans I think it were over six hundred
and twenty nine thousand that was a
conforming limit okay show you you you
know you look at big that flagpole is it
that flag you you know listen you could
you could get in here for a relative you
would think those loans to be hard to
sell the banks to be hardly like to make
a lot yeah they had to show a lot more
reserves out show a lot but it was still
these houses dude are really nothing
compared to the handle it's got a little
lake here it's nice like the HAMP if you
go out to the Hamptons you'll forget it
I mean they I mean this is like nothing
compared to the head the Hamptons are
yeah it's it's like you'd be like is
that a hotel no that's a home right now
I mean this is pretty this is pretty uh
but it's nice I used to do we used to
smoke pot and drive around here because
there's nobody ever around here they
don't even have a private police force
that's visible they do I mean there was
somebody pulling somebody over they do
you gotta be a little careful with them
right um like I don't hedges it looks
like yeah I mean did people here a
little down to earth I think I mean in
their minds yeah our hedge a quarter
hedge I'm not too good for so where are
we lost lost so now we're gonna show you
how I was doing you also when you get I
noticed when you get up here the North
Shore your cellphone just stops working
yes and like you scream it's not even
I'm sure they don't have to say yeah you
can't you can't be good trying to go
over like some of these houses
times may be out Stan's point per se but
kind of next level down maybe I would
come into their home to program a party
and uh yeah like you get lost you came
in GPS no you they don't they're there
no they want you out yeah they want ya
the cell tower and you're they won't
they're not gonna put a cell tower in
here look at this guy just walk a lot of
people just walk in the side of the road
he should be walking against traffic
that's the way I was in the Boy Scouts
so that you can see cars and jump out of
the way you have to this is Sands Point
Road we're trying to find sans light
Road what's on there well that's when
you see celebrity to kill me wait yeah
that's we're gonna take it that's what
you're gonna see some bananas Holmes and
I just don't know he looks all waste a
big Cove area right yeah it's also nice
it's also nice in the John McEnroe's
home I mean outside of it why were you
why knew of me we knew a kid and I
worked with who can you can you just
Google rice sands light Road on your
let's see my have a [ __ ] connection
you'll have a connection
usually I'll tell you one thing I'm glad
we grew up how we grew up yeah I mean
would you really want to have this
bunkie on your back yes yes yes they're
quite the answer is yes I want to live
up it was clearly being facetious
so I was clearly kidding when I said I'm
glad we grew up with boomer parents who
fed us poison I feel like I'm rested
though most people would feel that way
and understanding of the world works has
gotten us a lot yeah in a real big
benefit sans light Road it's been a real
big benefit to us directions you mean
yeah I just want to show you this one
little part of it and then we can head
to the cider mill oh we can get you some
cider for the cleanup drink them goddamn
so why are you not having cider tons of
sugar ray its kedo i yes exactly I had a
week in this body perfecting this body
you you have you had the krump I know
ray its Kido is not keno its way ray
it's not ray the crumbs Akito the keto
crumbs okay this is why we're still fat
you always act like yo oh and when I say
yeah I was running five miles a day they
met Tammy like you got fat in your own
and how they you
when we take responsibility my point is
do you like every night let's go to Taco
Bell
let's go you also wanted to go to Taco
Bell free I'm not saying it's your never
running away you ran for a while then
stopped running I didn't tell you to
stop writing though I'm just saying that
you're a bad influence where I guess so
can you find Sam's location services on
God it's my fault Taco Bell is it great
that's the only fast-food I care about
yeah you know I'm gonna the trouble over
the why didn't you get like a tofu
burger for like killing us yeah I
attacked the top uber guy because he
wouldn't take this you talk about cuz
he's being a dick so since light road
he's being a dick sans light Road it
shouldn't be that hard to support
Washington no it's not but maybe it is
maybe they call this maybe they call
this well Washington they're home half
an hour away
now it's you're out of your mind it's
literally hold on I think we're almost
here right ray is completely out of his
mind
I'm going by Google it's not that where
I think no it's not at home so slight
rule you would say his point lighthouse
no okay right right we're on our way I
think we're here I think well I'm
telling you I know how to get where
we'll go I feel the way the rich the
wealthy under I understand the wealthy
and the wealthy understand me and that's
why I've been able to no LoJack in your
ass that's exactly right yeah uh I think
I'm in the wrong spot actually I don't
know yeah it's probably wrong
I'm telling you Google tell me a
half-hour away it's not that no it's
right around here right
hmm I mean you you you you you're not it
says Sands Point Road sans like Road
Sands Point New York I'll tell you and
it's a half hour away
we're in Sands Point I mean is I they've
got their maze so clean Metroid No
no look the same always [ __ ] houses Oh
big man show big houses Realtors we use
reverse psychology oh you live here you
want a big mansion that's the road I
think Cornwell's Beach Road I think is
the foremost Bistro not sands like one
was take you to sand you fat slob well
you're a real man you were Mansion the
Rope we were already on I'll tell you
right now use temperatures are starting
to turn off didn't you know oh here it
is
everything I've done I've done for the
Lord here it is I actually never got
myself I always know what real money is
I should never ever should never look at
these house hands and this is the big
money best to esteem of a goddamned
driveway right if you bring up the steep
steep driveway again I'm gonna throw you
out can community center so here's we're
gonna get to the Schrader whatever you
wanna go get a pack of cigarettes or a
taco I'll give the [ __ ] their home
now bend look take I want been to see
some mouth take a look Ben C Ben to see
through the hedges can you see it
you can't see it I see stuff oh it's a
good field well this is play is blah
it's not blood that's it the beautiful
home was a batting cage nice okay we'll
see it on Google image later slow
children playing I don't see children
here all day are they talking about see
these men this is the real money see
this it's real money yeah there's that
private house they'd let you see it from
the street it's a good you know what ray
I don't entirely disagree with you
I actually don't entirely disagree
nobody you know they want privacy and
everything but it's
I don't know why your window was rolled
down then your window should not be down
your comfort is not paramount you're
working okay
fat-ass raised right you are disgusting
you are gross and then you wind on these
mics take a lot take a look see this
yellow [ __ ] Patchogue right I know
that you're not impressed by anything
and grew up in Texas in a bag of Fritos
well I was in the ocean a month ago it's
fine this is a wicker fence like a
booger basket what is this they like
shaped like stalks of wheat
this is nice actually it'd be nice if we
didn't say no parking yeah it does kind
of ruin it back you people don't get it
rolling it you know who's gonna park
here anyway I didn't get blown over here
some guys blowing his babysitter do be
funny for my aunt's car broke down and
we had to explain to her why we were all
the way in Sands Point I would probably
just block every one of my family and
get out of here instead of explaining
why we were in this wealthy area don't
forget some drugs throw them in the car
first and then yeah right throw some
coke frame my hair frame my aunt but it
is you know listen man there's something
about living by the water dude I gotta
be honest you know it's a beautiful way
to live yeah these houses are probably a
suspect I mean that's true but a lot of
these people really kind of like natural
disasters you know they enjoy them you
know because they're like yeah our house
got [ __ ] but that a million other
houses got [ __ ] yeah you know they
called the sukkah fund suck fun you're
sucking and [ __ ] what's going on
my name is Raymond and I'm the new tutor
one of the doors
oh no to teach the kids it's not just
Asians I'm very good actually
I'm here teaching the humanities and
every morning it's a beautiful house
what kind berries do you think those are
like expensive berries on the trees
why don't you go eat once you collapse
what is this fenced off it is the Hobbit
there's stone fence Leah cobbles let's
just go in their driveway see what
happens I mean you know what if I had a
license I would I really would I'm not
kidding if I had a license that was in
my car I would I love the idea we're
just try really we're almost definitely
gonna get pulled over at some point and
would get away with it if you had a
license well I don't think we're gonna
get pulled over right first of all
people know who I am like when they see
me seeing you on the understand I've
been on truTV it's fun when somebody
meets the celebrity you know I know
heaven live at Gotham don't worry so
much premium blend don't worry about it
this guy was great that guy why not he's
white done bad things it's all over sir
wouldn't it be funny if we just looked
in on what this is for Asian chatham
this is for the kids
this is her what you did it koala Lepore
it's just nice knowingly he just nods he
accepts his faith that was sands point
what's everyone's think uh little tacky
I don't think it's worth all the war
crimes that's a good point it seems like
is this really like I pictured like
good-looking I'm not [ __ ] you know he
comes really Horus about to say
something that doesn't I think if you
say like I'm not Rick clasher ban no I I
don't meet a bleeding-heart here but
like you know like if you kill one guy
they get a mansion yeah right by me like
starting a yeah I run the cops in the
minivan your bike got a bike stop sign
stop sign Jesus Christ
try not to peel rubber
but yeah I mean I I feel like you know I
could see killing you robbing a bank
killing you gotta get some money but I
mean to start a fake war I think you
would get more than this more than like
you know a little privacy at a house by
the water I mean just like thousands of
camp millions of Cambodian kids dead and
like oh I can finish off my dock and the
you know it just doesn't seem like
enough they have multiple properties
right and you have to realize a lot of
those houses you didn't see they were
beautiful the hedges were very nice
they're not seeing the inside of them
they're gorgeous
so you've been in the kitchen I'm just
saying like you've never been an asset
it's exposed barn-style and the kitchen
is beautiful and it's very high ceiling
know what's exposed barns that like you
know like with the beams and everything
it's nice no Cathedral yeah alright damn
mouth those guys smoking a cigarette
cool
oh you're cool guy I mean you right now
into your party there's not nice well
once you get out of this you're out of
this these people getting an Escalade
roll the windows up and they don't look
they don't look out the window again
till they're in their office in Midtown
right I mean it seems so far from even
the lae that's like an extra 45 minutes
to get home money this here build their
will Enclave closer to the I just suck
off this guy who's like a young kid
who's like 20 and he worked at a dairy
barn around here and his family also
worked in dairy barns they were like a
dairy barn family but they had pride in
it and it was the saddest thing ever
there's nothing sadder than a whole
family who works at a shitty job I know
a guy who worked the dairy barn who got
shot in the face and died like he's like
here I work a dairy barn because my dad
does it's like oh that's not the way
that's supposed to work but I tell you
this the guy the dairy barn by being he
got killed shot in the face one night
know why someone was robbing the dairy
barn and you want my window up by a
child locks on my goddamn window why was
somebody rolling why was somebody so
somebody just shot him in the face yeah
well did he get loud or something maybe
he didn't want maybe he said like
all the money or like please to think it
starts a you know Long Island wiseass
hey what are you gonna do with this
money oh you got what 300 bucks what are
you gonna buy a house probably deserved
and he desert getting some lead in his
face this is the marina we saw before
it's a it's a schlocky marina it's like
it's like anything you see in [ __ ] uh
you know within her store patch hog it's
just another big nothing further [ __ ]
about mother it's okay that was a little
pressed I'm not impressed doesn't matter
to me I don't give a [ __ ] about nothing
I don't care I don't care what you do
that woman looks nice in Grumpy Old Men
would you what's the old as you go I
mean I didn't hook up with fifty
three-year-old once
yeah that's right yeah explain the
circumstances of that we were both just
drunk trash the bar I was some bar up on
like okay it was like we ended up on it
was when I was over living in like
Holbrooke or like it wasn't portion
really I think yeah I got a woman who
Shay she wasn't she a slender woman had
a big tuft of hair big a big matted hair
a big yeah Jerry curly kind of vibe not
bad I show P I had a picture of her
later playing pool sure she was a
beautiful woman cool she wasn't bad she
had a nice body and she kicked me out in
the mornings I was snoring but you know
we in the me made love for uh wait a
minute hold on no you made love well I
don't know actually can perform we're
pretty drunk the gift to go dalla Monta
Democrat for town Kansas hey
[Laughter]
[ __ ] is [ __ ] can you fix this I tried
to my house
some guy Toby not conscious [ __ ] nuts
this place is called I love hearing dude
that's how we market goods and services
now just things you should be able to do
I love walking I mean I want to go to I
love walking you're the windows back
down a hot box in here I love well I
mean the undo the child locked in just
goes this is the regular rep anyway no
it's a fire chief well just cops
everywhere we go different cops stop
being a [ __ ] man you [ __ ] [ __ ]
logistics yeah well I made one bar I
think she had been cut off I was pretty
drunk and then she want some my beer I
gave her some and then like when we like
actually girl get out of here I'm like
yeah sure and then we got to my car oh I
forgot my shoes she was barefooted I
realized at this moment and like where
are your shoes she's like iron inside
somewhere and like I said one of them
and so I went in when like they already
kind of kicked her out
were you real happy she was gone I'm
like anyone seen her shoe she's missing
a shoe no like what no and like they
were I went in the garbage you were
looking for shoes in the garbage we're
looking for this woman shoes in the
garden ice guy yeah they gave up like
when I came back they don't have your
shoe and we just left and we went to a
smaller borrow some other bars she
doesn't show me you better buy drinks
this bar but she end up buying all the
drinks like that what what season was it
what mine I think you would like to fall
okay so she's shoeless in the fall yeah
maybe a spring maybe the spring only it
was summer okay and you go to the next
bar and she buys all the drinks no she
was 53 uh I think she told me at what
point do you decide that you and her are
going to go home no matter mommy I
like that but I mean at what point I
kind of don't we're going home
oh we got to my place for we went back
to my place at one point my diary there
the cat well yeah well she came in she
like this place smells like cat piss
wrong oh yeah I couldn't change his
litter box more often I'll admit right
um so you would so weird I thought I was
done so I don't really op that's it no
but no one's getting late night let's go
to my place and so we did and we go she
had nice I mean maybe your son just died
or something I don't know because she
came to have like a nice house and like
she didn't see it was much nicer than
you would think it wasn't like a rundown
shitty house it's a nice house and
somewhere like this mentality or
whatever hakama and like it was well
kept we danced a Van Morrison before we
got on the bed what song I forget
probably girl probably Jesus
maybe with uh I mean the visuals of this
are so harrowing I mean this is a horror
film this is an absolute horror film I
mean that is a scene in a horror film
that's talked about over and over people
like did you see when they were dancing
a brown eyed girl right before it
collapse I mean I can't even imagine I'm
like what was the worst part of it with
the bloodletting no not even that no
torture scenes now they danced a
brown-eyed girl
where were you dancing in the kitchen Oh
God um yeah yeah you know we got a dress
that we got in the bed then I can't
remember what happened well I remember I
remember not beyond getting erect uh Wow
whiskey hug and then what happened
sleeping then next thing I know she's
waking me up she's yelling at me I go
you have to go and then like so I'm like
I'm rushing out the door like it's a
movie she's marriage maybe but she's
like I don't go that fast like I was
like I'm like popping around like taking
my pants off okay and uh oh what a sweet
lady yeah well look I mean maybe if I
got if I
giving her a nice a nice bit of pipe
maybe she would have been a little less
uh I had just hated about my snoring or
whatever so then you don't keep in touch
with her I did not we don't get her a
yearbook
hi everybody
the under on that Pat that night the bar
we went through they seemed to know who
she was she was a regular I'm sure they
did she was dancing we're dancing at one
point in the bar with she had no shoes
to what song I think just a Miley Cyrus
song or something yeah we were playing
pool I was like doing anything I was
holding her waist like well she's
teaching I play pool oh god I'm thinking
of a montage of this it just ends with
911 like he somehow you guys made 911
happen how to play pool dancer the brown
eyed girl next thing I know two towers
in New York City found next thing I know
there's goddamn planes flying in a
[ __ ] building she wakes me up
teachers get up get up work war the
country's at war there's a window they
were in the road I mean yeah look I mean
she was a sweet lady I like cider you
like apple cider yeah look it makes you
[ __ ] badly he's going right through you
it's black people [ __ ] and my friend's
mother what does that mean meaning that
they have a sensitive system apple juice
apple just makes me [ __ ] okay it's very
uh that might be a thing yeah it's good
it's like I'm not sure it's a god
babe there's never been a Jeremy's house
in Freeport if you've been there rang uh
I think so it's great apple juice has a
lot of fiber and Suicider
and so that that's part of the the
ballgame when it comes to [ __ ] he's
having a lot of fiber liquid fiber
inside you I have to do shows tonight at
the stand I really don't even want to
there's a nice country club mandala
which was this
I don't know Sands Point comes from
something like done maybe it's North
Hills I forget yeah I don't even want to
show it like dude I do shows in New York
it's just rich people you know it's just
wealthy young people and you're like oh
I'm kind of you're like I'm barely I'm
like not as excited or what you do like
i market you know my new roommate is a
jewel salesperson exactly someone sells
jewel stuff
you mean the vape yeah but I don't like
their work at a bodega like they like a
corporate salesperson okay so you know
and they're living with you they must be
doing well
yeah so you ever heard you and Lucy and
then him that's a woman oh yeah what's
her deal I mean she seems she wants to
get a dog we told she couldn't she might
try to get a dog anyway and I'm I don't
want to kill the dog I'm not gonna hurt
the dog but you know is there anything I
could do to like move in with someone
who's hell-bent on getting a dog
no she burned that out up frosh would be
we don't have any power we'd already put
the deposit and she came in she not only
was our place and she like you know it's
like oh you moved in her place no we
both is a building an apartment building
yes so shouldn't you have sat down and
had a little meeting of the minds about
pets but we did then she said every
great great she wouldn't get a dog I was
just worried that she's gonna break her
because like we got there and in the
least
it's like written in like she can she
can have a dog I'm like what's this all
about like you know that she could she's
got there before us it was like is she
gonna get a dog and like in she's trying
like back end the deal here and she's
like now cuz the lease says you can't
have dogs but you actually allowed to so
she said she wouldn't get the dog so i
bribe road and made lucy sign you know
this whole thing of like we do not want
a dog yeah I'm just wondering if there's
any tactics I could use to it's just if
she tries to score to get a dog throwing
stuff in the garbage I mean I love this
already a war right now we're nice we're
just anticipating a war I'm always a
dissipating jewel I'm getting ready to
throw her [ __ ] out okay she might get a
dog what else could I do
smear some blood on the door
I'm ready I'm always ready to meet this
person the building recruited her and
you and Lucy understand this they're
like hey you could move in here but you
gotta live with this fat guy in his
check oh I come in the apartment you're
like it I live here it's all gonna
[ __ ] dog I'll beat the [ __ ] outta you
I'll [ __ ] kill ya all right
I mean it's it's amazing to me look I
want a nice place a little fun it's not
that nice I mean you know we have a
refuge yeah that's nice yeah you've seen
this like a room where you throw the
garbage in no you have a shoot and like
the recycling goes no it's just a room
and you don't go outside it's nice it's
nice buildings go Jim and the basements
nice oh I see what you mean when you're
in Brooklyn you're enjoying it a Brooke
I'm enjoying it my roof is wonderful I
was hoping you yo day on the phone I was
looking at the Freedom Tower oh good oh
good for you right it was nice of you I
was there last night I was at the 9/11
mall yeah ball we've been to oh yeah oh
yeah strange they build that out of the
car the whole thing is built from
repurposed parts of the buildings yeah
yeah I mean I like a whale card it's
really it's a it's a joke that you'd
make and somebody would tell you not to
be inappropriate and it's then the
reality is it's legitimately a mall yeah
you be that you'd be literally ads of
like the old old memorial site when I'm
reading the names back I'm like oh three
yeah hey like yeah five years are gonna
be a profit here yeah like shut up shut
up stop now it's exactly what it is yeah
but recently alcohol that years ago he's
like aw people with selfies taking
selfies you know taking selfies means
I'll just add some more it's it's one of
the most affluent moles I've ever seen
in my life
oh it's firmly yeah only exclusively
rich stores we had the you know the
false flags got to be worth something
yeah
you know I can't do nobody did a
false-flag to move in a Walmart we known
as for Denny's yeah Mont Blanc pens you
[ __ ] you want to sign contracts with a
nice pen yeah I think everyone now
accepts it today is shady and I don't
mean everyone but like most people in
our generation and younger the day you
shady whoa 911 oh that way you guys have
a new term for the 11th the day no I
just say a [ __ ] like the day oh yeah
well I'm just saying I think after
Epstein and after everything that
everybody's seen oh yeah everybody's
kind of like revisiting that in their
own head going yeah it doesn't make any
sense there was that point like when
when the JFK film came out people were
still like flock there's also but I feel
like by 2002 or four and we're seeing
the Iraq war we know something's crooked
like yeah they probably killed Kennedy
it takes you 20 30 years yeah are they
ever gonna like know for sure
probably not but like just like in at 78
or like 85 whatever they're some House
Committee has like so they can clue
there's a probable evidence is very
suitable conspiracy
I guess show someone did something
whatever you say but yeah so 9/11 I mean
people kind of like I don't I don't know
how you could see the Iraq war now and
the whole path of it cuz cancer is one
thing you have gasps there we go there
every the courts [ __ ] but you know
it makes sense at least on paper but
like the amount of people who were
convinced that Saddam Hussein was behind
them and that like and just the leaps we
made any reasonable person would have to
[Music]
sure do you know where the northern
state is oh it's that way
that way oh thank you
I think he's pointing to the LE well
this Norden say this is Britt look at
the breaking stuff yeah cuz I'm trying
to get to the the cider mill why don't
you put decidable on your phone I want
Ben to see the fall the way we do at
Long Island are you into this either mu
you've never been to the cider me think
you brought home what kind of dumb [ __ ]
are you
I went to yeah pink firms Yeah right
it's not everyone's fault you've 900
pounds um Derek Slater moon yes no
they're not Sunday - better not be
closed in Jericho correct what does it
say to do is 50 willows by train it's
not 50 I mean either by train maybe
that's the problem before it was by
train I guess 11 minutes away
[Music]
no he [ __ ] oh yeah yeah the expressway
I know what I'm doing I'm that guy
slide left onto the i-495 wouldn't be
funny if that GPS was like there are
lanes going east there lanes and then
there are lanes going straight to hell
why just so backed up it's backed up you
know everybody's gonna see their mom I'm
gonna see my mama this Sunday mama
Meghan do meatballs I gotta talk about
that great rumpus you know you know when
we would go out to dinner Doreen
required me when I would talk about
Mexicans now it's all good she goes you
let it fly
where you get off no maybe like I you
give me think I really uses this is a
dick move it's not a dick you're just
like classic like you know just shitty
personal things sorry that I'm a winner
you we have an HOV Lane you can use for
I was sorry then
winner yeah but how long Leon this oh
let's see for two minutes right six
point four miles Oh we'll get into the
HOV is that really on the weekends is
even the thing people seem to avoid it
though
think about the HIV is that even though
it's only active from like you for two
hours on in the morning in two hours a
night during the week people avoid it at
the other time so you can get in there
when you're allowed to use there's a
Long Island tip from Ray so if you're
drunk
is that in the HOV it's fine
you only have one D way I have a DW AI
what does that mean driver impaired but
still keep yeah I can than in many
situations you can take your chances
right but have you come up for the live
part I could wrist it and I would say I
would like gone back and cuffs I
wouldn't mind it I didn't want to like
risk you being out the money or whatever
so I appreciate it yeah yeah it takes a
while okay I think it's a retaliatory
thing because we put some restrictions
on Canada or maybe because of what we do
with Mexico Canada is like no we're
gonna [ __ ] you guys know right let me do
that right yeah
I get it yes I didn't get my nasal spray
on my bag man push me towards the top
then this is a bag there's just a spider
well this is roast beef and cheese in
there that's my spider
here's my pack what about water like I'm
excited to my whistle I'm excited for
you to go to the cider mill for the
first time ramen I mean I can't eat
enjoy you me and you but you can enjoy
it all ramen
will we have any thick cut bacon they
have candy bacon dipped an apple glaze
good they don't have that even I mean
look there's the Applewood forums too
maybe they have that stuff there how
about they have Swiss roll ice cream
well I got Swiss roll but with ice cream
its yum yum mmm there's a lot of good
food there for all the fat sickles all
the fatties
this whole thing or the seven people
come the fast Suffolk people come out no
fat Suffolk people stay in there huh
Suffolk really is until you to the
Hamptons will dump your problems quite
nice this sickness NASA is the whole
like NASA is the character in the
culture I mean I grew up in Suffolk so I
just agree mom
dude Nassau County anthem was much
better now so kind of state of mind and
Suffolk tried to do it what's up we do
they were like we're gonna Flanders doc
it was like horrific now what is this
nasal spray for slash make me up you
dick to spray no people can can you get
on your phone and tell me where to go to
get to the I mean this is how much how
much [ __ ] oh that's crazy
that's not good for you these static
sailing all right that's it it's
saltwater there's nothing else in there
nothing three point eight miles all
right you know I mean I'm trying to take
care of my it makes me money this voice
yeah yeah uh so this is the expressway
really doesn't have a lot of charm no
it's kind of a dull road to drive them
the northern state definitely has a
little more of a scenic aspect to it but
it was built in racism and so I it's a
trade-off right it's trade-off because
on one hand is racist but on the other
hand it's charmless that's not really
what a trade-off state someone in those
your state are more charming
right now it's understandable that's
what I'm saying that's the trade-off I
mean trying to do certain parts of
northern state it's quite nice my
Hofstra I had drive here every day I
went to Hofstra for a year and I failed
Japanese why did you take Japanese again
like Japanese cinema
I like the anime at the time right I
thought it'd be kind of cool I'm who
doesn't wanna go to Japan Japan seems
like a five-letter Japan it's - it's too
pricey right yeah
it's not it's not it's not you know it's
not feasible right um so yeah but it's a
hard language to learn
watashi no tango I film this what does
that mean
my major is film what are three though
that you're walking around Japan like
what I'm saying that cyber Sam Radford
that's for me that's read two point
three months five minutes five minutes
away apparently yeah this is a great
this is your again when I was a child I
would go because my grandfather lived in
mountain town had a pool and a tennis
court two and a half acres it's not a
big deal eight bathrooms in the home and
the point is that we would then go to
get cider and maybe and then I ever
known that I'll bring an apple crumb pie
to you know an event and I'll get it
from here are you gonna eat at the cider
mill what do you mean these treats there
I'm just a happy with me I'm saying
no no idiot uh we're gonna eat jeromy's
later we can eat Jeremy's with Hermes
Jeremy's Yale has a free port okay me
and pan are getting Buffalo shrimp ooh
and all this good stuff get a steak no
it's dude it's all Kido okay dude Kido
is a state of mind
oh do you know what I mean like it's not
so a specific set of nutritional
guidelines okay it's a state of mind
like you can be keto and eat bread you
can be keto and have ice cream I mean
it's just keto and have sugar you're
like Paul Wolfowitz believe in yourself
yes dude you could be six in two pounds
and you can just go on keto
I should be a rapper called Kido Kido
come every is a really fat rapper I
don't eat carbs
I smoked mobs I don't eat carbs I'm ki
dope like this is horrific
I come not carbs are you still making
EDM music and I used to pursue your
career as an EDM DJ we pursuing a career
but yes I'm still I just move we went
through a little bit of a transition
moving but I'm getting my stuff set back
up but yeah I haven't got off here do
you want to oh yeah bro 640 41 yeah
you should ask me that my new passion
and your I'm like the I'm sorry I missed
it
I was wrong exit I know yeah North yeah
but we can get there right from here
should be I guess I mean this is for
yeah let's just go let's go north the
Lord there uh
Kido come yeah I mean I program beats I
mean I ever knew I put a link on my
Twitter soon maybe today so people can
check out my beats on the SoundCloud you
know I'm just doing my thing ain't run
you know run the world hear the beats
word up bro I'll go show after we get
some cider we'll see more of my
grandfather live and then we'll head
down south shore yeah and we will have
lunch or a lot late lunch yeah when the
Jordans
were Lobster no hat we could go there
too actually but he's a mobster it's
gonna [ __ ] fool good you can go to the
fit you go to Jeremy's get any fish you
want all right I mean yes but I mean you
know Jeremy's also has like mozzarella
sticks roasted cookie dough yes you can
they're breaded bread is okay on kita oh
god dude bread is all right what keto
are you doing the key oh where you
actually lose weight I'm sorry the key
where you look at can I tell you the
rules of Quito yeah say it would be
after me ready yes
I'm key now I'm Quito that's it it's
like a prayer if you say I'm Quito
before what you eat it's okay okay if
you look at a loaf of bread to go I'm
key how these friends you have out in
California that once you bet these guys
who like you you're your betters no but
the guys you trying to impress yeah
are they gonna like you know if you if
you stay fat you're talking sure about
Quito I know staying sad I've lost a lot
of weight I'm continuing to lose weight
well yeah
continuing program and the Moses were
out of the ghost was here to the ride
entertainment program and I work here
that was Otto the girl the mill ratings
they're what I'm a Russian mother of the
Pravda groom I think she wanted to [ __ ]
me she was uh dancing with me if I
states that are my friends gonna be my
friends I don't know maybe I'm just
saying you're talking about [ __ ] they
seem to care about Quito a lot and
you're saying I'm on Quito and you're
hurting the image you're seeing Rogen
well one person was like I could kill
him out you're running your mouth and
Brogan's gonna be like look you're
making my Kido thing look bad he doesn't
do 'quite um yeah wait I think there's
the primate diet right he does something
but he has carbs but he just works out a
lot now I'm losing I have an overall
commitment to losing weight everyone
knows that or it everyone knows that but
I'm also a comedian I'm also here to
entertain people we're gonna be off of
Mike and you're gonna be eating the
doughnuts not true it's Kate you dumb
[ __ ] I just more than I thought it would
be oh we're get rear-ended as guys downs
alright relax your whole unit how you
gonna [ __ ] lighten his Long Islanders
just a well you're being a maniac you're
blocking the driver here this was a I
hold on we got to go get some keto
snacks
we're stopping
[Music]